- We do have a question.
So if you all want to
pop your questions in,
we do have one question from Joanne,
asking if there could
be some clarification
around CoV-2's, SARS-CoV-2's
requirement for reverse
transcription in the central dogma.
So I don't know if you
want to just sort of like,
clarify that aspect.
- So, so there's, well,
if I went back to the screen of the,
should I go back to the--
- You can, yeah if it's
helpful, go for to it.
- [Andres] Okay,
okay, so when it goes
from this RNA molecule
to this messenger RNA,
it uses a, what we call, is a polymerase
or this is just a fancy
word for saying a protein
that copies this to another molecule.
So it uses,
it's a polymerase that
makes RNA, based off of RNA.
So obviously, that's not the way
DNA is transferred to
mRNA, so for the virus,
it's not really a reverse situation
but it's the kind of molecules
that are cells used to make
reversed transcription.
I guess, I don't know,
did that make any sense?
- Yeah, I think, like,
it's always like, tricky
'cause when we, we're so
used to learning everything
in these, like, DNA based systems, right?
And so, remembering that they're an RNA,
and that they have to go
backwards, and then forwards,
and like, all of these things,
and that they're also
replicating each other,
and like, there's a lot
of biology going on.
- In this case, it's just going forward.
- Yeah, and I think
there's also the difficulty
since the way that
we're doing the testing,
for us to be able to work with that,
you need to be able to make DNA
and that's whether reverse
transcriptase comes in for us.
So we have a question
from Katherine Sultani,
who asks, if the genome
sequence can be studied now
for COVID-19, or I guess,
the new coronavirus,
can that help us with
predicting future coronaviruses?
- It may, and so there's even, you know,
a lot of the research that
has been done to study
the receptor binding domain,
has come from research
from studying the original coronavirus.
So, it's not just all this
research just happened,
but it's actually many
years of understanding
the structure of the genome and so,
if this also mutates further,
it could also help us understand
if the current coronavirus changes
in ways that are important.
- Great, thanks!
And that was my cousin.
Hello Katie, hope you're well.
(laughs)
Okay, so we have a question
from Facebook, from Peggy.
Do you know if there have
been mutations observed
since the outbreak began in humans?
- So, there have been some mutations,
but those mutations, well,
so in general,
mutations can occur and
viruses can occur mutations
for example, more faster
than, than we can.
And so, there can be lots
of different mutations
and again, it's also about if all the DNA,
or all the genes or genomes of the viruses
are being sequenced properly.
But, there's two mutations
that have occurred in,
that have kind of been passed along,
and that have allowed
people to really track
different populations.
But whether those mutations
are affecting people
in different ways, that
hasn't really been answered.
- Cool, okay so, question
from Lauren Freed which is,
how do scientists know
to look for the virus
in bats and pangolins?
Is there a reason behind
why bats carry so many coronaviruses?
- I think, so one of the
things to think about
is that viruses are just all around us,
so it's one of the most abundant types
of genetic material,
or, like, living being,
or almost living being, that there is.
So there's even viruses
that infect viruses,
and we may have other kinds of viruses
that aren't infecting us so much.
But it's just, I guess,
known from prior studies
that, that bats host a lot
of these coronaviruses,
probably after the initial
outbreaks, it was a race to find.
But also, that's part of this collecting
different materials
from different animals.
Some people even during times
when there's not an outbreak,
they're just collecting lots of viruses
from different animals.
A pangolin actually had
symptoms that are, or that were
very like what coronavirus is now.
And so, it was probably
just standard procedure
that they kept the tissues
and the cells of the pangolin
and, I'm not sure if they
sequenced the gene right away
but maybe they, once they saw
the, you know, similarities,
then they may have.
- Yeah thanks, and I think
also, I know that there are
bat people who are very
specifically studying coronaviruses
in bats, so they're more
like bat ecologists.
And then there's virology people
who are studying coronaviruses,
who are now also,
or, who have been for many years,
stop talking about bats as a
reservoir for other things.
So it's a, this is not something that,
I just wanted to also add
that that is not something that is new.
Everybody has, in the
scientific communities,
have known that coronaviruses
are these things
that are existing in bats
for a really long time,
and so, there is a quite
a bit of literature
on coronaviruses and
bats, all over the place.
So I'm going to ask a Facebook question,
another Facebook question from Carolina.
And the question is around
how we can easily explain to others,
what a lab signature is,
maybe in a simple way,
and just following up on that,
how easy it would be to create
a virus like this in the lab.
And I also want to preface
this question with just saying,
viruses have been around
for billions of years,
humans have not.
You know, so they're
incredibly sophisticated.
So I'll just throw it at you now.
- Yeah and so, what I
mean by lab signature is,
they're usually specific genes
that people use that make things resistant
to different drugs or,
allow us to see them under
a microscope and they,
like, for example, turn green,
and so, those allow us to
really look at things or,
like, otherwise just,
kind of, enrich for them
to make them actually study-able.
Otherwise they'll be, kind of,
mixed up with all the other viruses.
And so, I don't know if
that clarified or if--
- Yeah, we call them like,
little selection tags.
You know, in the lab, so
I don't know if that's,
it just helps to make sure
that they remain concentrated.
- Yeah, it's like being able
to stick a label on something
and then being able to pick
it out at a later date.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And so, so like, for
example, now, this coronavirus,
the new coronavirus, has been taken
and put in to those kinds of sequences
so that people can study them,
and really figure out how they work
and so that we can create
drugs and stuff like that.
So it's, it's not an
impossible thing to do but,
we would expect that if this virus
was out there infecting people,
that we would be able
to see that signature
from the sequences of patients
that have had coronavirus.
- And do you think it's easy to create
a something like this, in a lab?
- Well the thing is, yeah,
we don't really know.
Like, nature has a lot of opportunities,
and we have a lot less,
kind of, foresight
to know actually what's going to create,
be all the things that can
create a very, very deadly virus.
Currently, we know now that
this virus is very deadly,
but that's only in hindsight.
- Yeah, so I feel like (mumbles) and I,
are becoming firm friends,
I always ask her questions.
So she has a two-parter
and this is, is there a specific mechanism
for pangolins or bats to
transmit the virus to humans?
And how would this be different
from human to human transmission?
- Well, I don't think there's a specific,
you know, anything different that humans
transferring it from...
It's just the way that people
interact with these animals.
So for example, the
pangolin that was found,
these don't naturally live in China,
they're found in different
areas of the world
and this was, they're
usually trafficked animals,
and so, you know, just not
having that interaction
with that pangolin would've
helped if it wasn't trafficked.
The bats, obviously, are not,
or I don't now if they're,
how people are interacting with bats.
But it's just, you know, if you're,
how you behave or interact with things
in close proximity, right?
- So this is a really great
question from Tiffany,
and that is around the implication
that SARS-CoV-2 is 96%
related to the bat sequences
that were examined here, yet,
the receptor binding domain is
more similar to the pangolin.
You know, what does that mean?
- So, I guess one possibility is that,
so the way I showed how
the genes of the virus get transmitted,
it happens, like, in this
very step wise fashion.
It's like one mutation, next mutation.
But also, sometimes the
strains of different viruses
can mix together.
So different regions and mutations
can then transfer.
So it could be possible that
a coronavirus like the one
that is seen in the bat,
also mixed with the one
found that's in the pangolin.
And another possibility is that
there was already one like
the one that we saw now,
but it just wasn't sequenced.
- So we have a quick question
from Joanna, which is,
is this virus present in pangolin saliva?
- I'm not, I'm not sure,
- Yeah, I was thinking, just
in case this was something
that was mentioned in the
course of writing this paper
like how they were, the
animals were sampled for the,
to be able to detect the virus.
- Right, yeah.
I think they just took the tissues from,
actually it was two dead pangolins.
And they had died from
coronavirus-like symptoms
and, and so, yeah, I don't know
how they took the samples from them.
- So I think there is a
question that is asking around
like maybe, are there other animals
that could have also
contributed to this whole thing,
and so like, why did the
scientist focus only on the bats
and the pangolins?
Were there other things or
maybe, are there other things
that are not even in our range
of thought or understanding?
- So, the reason why they
focus on it is because,
they found similarities
from those sequences
that were in that catalog.
And so the way this worked is actually,
they didn't even sequence the
whole genome of the viruses,
so they just sequenced a specific region,
a specific protein that the virus has.
And they first assessed like,
how similar in that region,
and then they actually have
to do a lot of sequencing,
so it's actually quite
a lot of work because,
they can't, it's very difficult to,
to sequence the whole genome.
And so there are probably
different animals out there
with, with very, you know,
with coronavirus-like symptoms but,
but these are the ones that,
who were in the catalog.
So for example, I think we
know that cats can also,
they also have an ACE2-R+ receptor
that is very similar to humans,
and that allows for the new
coronavirus to bind to that.
And I'm sure there are other animals.
Camels were initially affected
in previous coronavirus outbreaks.
- Okay, so from Aditi again,
is the rate of mutations in pangolins
and bat coronaviruses,
parallel to that of humans?
- So, the rate of the
coronavirus should depend on
the actual coronavirus.
And it actually has some
proofreading when it's using,
it's replicating and has a proofreading
way to correct itself.
So it's rate of mutation is
slower than other viruses
that usually don't have
that proofreading ability.
But I don't, I wouldn't imagine
it depending on the host
but,
yeah.
- So we have a great
question around, from Anisa,
around ACE2.
And so like, what is it
normally, are, you know,
if you, if you're aware
of what ACE2 normally does in our bodies,
and then, you know, maybe why ACE2?
Why would the coronavirus use that
as the receptor?
If, if you even know,
I don't even know if we know that answer.
- Yeah so, I don't know what ACE2
is doing on the cell.
So I know that it's a receptor
and that it's expressed
on the cells of lungs
but other, other tissues as well.
But, I don't think it's the, kind of,
it's not like ,looking to take advantage
of the ACE2 receptor,
it's, the ACE2 receptor has, you know,
some structure that allows it to kind of,
enter cells and infect cells
and continue being able
to have its life cycle.
So if it, if it can't infect
cells through interacting
with the ACE2 receptor,
then it has to find a
different way to keep living.
- So, I had one question
before we tap out, I guess.
And this is more regarding where
the information for the paper came from.
So given that this is a review
and the people presenting the information
didn't do the experiments,
how did the authors choose the papers
that they didn't subsequently describe?
- So the way authors usually do this,
is that they review the
articles within the field
and they think of,
they use which is most relevant
to the kind of case that
they're trying to make,
and they also read the
papers very thoroughly
and try to establish which
one is more credible.
But yeah, it's mostly them looking
and actually developing this knowledge
over a long period of time of knowing
which, what is the research out there,
and what is everybody saying?
So, we have, kind of, different ways
of sharing information
from different meetings,
or just reading articles.
And so that's, and that's also why
seven different people
wrote this publication.
So, people have different
expertises that may overlap
but, there's gonna be things
that some people are more expert in.
- So we have a bunch of scientists
right now, on the panel,
and I'd like to maybe
open it up to everybody,
if anybody wants to join in,
but I was just wondering like, what your,
what are your thoughts
on the piece of research
and how we've been sharing
this information, like,
I mean, I personally feel
that I've never seen science
move so fast, in my life.
I feel like we're in like,
this like, Ferris Bueller situation
that if we don't stop and
look around, you know,
everything will pass us by?
And maybe, I don't know,
maybe Ferris Bueller is a bit
of a tell for my generation,
I don't even know if you know
who Ferris Bueller is, out there, but,
you know, and do you think
that this will change
the way we think about
doing science in the future,
and we think about collaboration,
and things like that?
- Is anybody else gonna?
- I don't know, does
anybody else want to join?
Or does anybody have any thoughts on that?
Or you can, you can start
us off if you want, Andres.
- Well, I think science is quite
a collaborative endeavor, already.
You know, there are some competition,
I think there's quite a lot of,
a lot of competition, but there's also
you know, this willingness
to share, as well.
That's increased a lot.
So there's a lot of people doing things,
and sharing everything more openly
and, trying to, kind of,
solve this problem together,
but, you know, if it's not
related to the pandemic,
I'm not sure if that kind
of feeling is gonna continue
or, you know.
- Right.
- [Andres] But...
- So, at some point, I
was working in a lab,
doing Alzheimer's research,
and it feels like for a very long time,
this has already been,
something that, as you say,
has been going at break-neck speed.
And I think that's partly due
to the scientific structure,
the fact that scientists
are expected to publish so many
papers that for Alzheimer's,
there's is just no
earthly way you could read
every relevant paper that
came out on a given day.
So, it'll be interesting to
see how this moves forward
because I think that potentially,
we don't need more information,
we just need it to be
more succinct and easier to translate,
and I know some people are
going through journal articles,
and they're trying to compile, you know,
the most relevant bits of
information from certain papers,
and I don't know how you do that
without losing any of the information.
But yeah, I wonder if
the course of COVID-19,
everything that's coming out,
if the results of it will help us hone
the amount of information coming out.
- Yeah I think yeah, I think all of,
I think your point, Andres, also on like,
will this apply to non
COVID stuff, I don't know.
That's a really fair point and so,
thanks for sharing that.